morning Hugh a man wants to open a bank
no this isn't going to amount to
anything come on we're lawyers we're on
the side whoever's paying us he's a
lawyer and he's from London but not all
that against him you would like to open
a bank the bank of Dave it's catchy very
catchy and the customers were having
problems making payments so I started
lending them me on money this isn't
about me making money every single penny
of profit goes straight to local
charities we're proposing a walk-in free
clinic I really think Dave could do some
good it's about the quality of life for
a whole Community this place is
constantly surprising me that may be out
for you yet
the financial regulation board hasn't
approved a new bank in 150 years once
Ordinary People start thinking they can
get in on the ACT the floodgates will
open the banks are literally a law unto
themselves I'm not part of the elite the
frb exists to make sure that people's
hard-earned money is entrusted to the
right kind of chat I told you they'd
fight dirty we need to fight back the
one thing you have on your side
everybody hates Bankers precisely this
is going to be the biggest night this
town has seen let's have some fun here
the concert is all to help Dave raise
the money to set up the country's very
first local bank he's managed them
amazing bands Def Leppard oh no shut up
no you don't
we're sending a message today
enough of you agreed There's A Better
Way well I put my money in Banker Dave
[Music]
oh you can't handle the truth oh I love
that film you know I've actually never
seen it you've not seen it I've just
seen that scene classic I love it Dave's
not seen it what I'm talking about but
can we bring it back to me please yes
[Music]